the medium is a next-gen psychological
horror game that plays
out across two realities our world and
the spirit world
thanks to the power of the hardware you
will be able to play in both worlds at
the same time
let's see how it works in action
at this point of the game marianne is
searching the manager's office
we render two fully fledged and visibly
different worlds simultaneously
so you can explore the physical and the
spirit version of the room
at the same time with no loadings at all
[Music]
thanks to the medium sense you can see a
secret passage behind the cabinet
[Music]
no figures there's gotta be a way to
power it up
let's see how you can use the
interactions between the realities
to open the entrance
as i moved the clock hand i realized it
was a junction
between realities
[Music]
is that thomas
there looks like a passage
a spirit well i could absorb some of
that energy
energy spots like this one let you
recharge marianne's psychic abilities
okay let's rewind to the opening
the entrance has opened in the spirit
world but the real world marienne
still can get in
marion's unique psychic ability the out
of body
lets her leave her physical self to
explore the spirit world
more freely
[Music]
another of your powers is the spirit
blast
you can use this energy against hostile
spirits
but also to charge up real world
electrical objects
[Music]
marianne cannot fully control her gift
to live in two words simultaneously
what what the [ __ ] is
this throughout the game
you will get to experience the worlds in
various combinations
and you will never know which word will
draw you in
next
truth
you